Patrick bid David come into your live
here well it's not live when you watch
it but I mean currently right now borj
al arab dubai this is our bedroom give
you the view here where i'm at this is
the view from our bedroom if you look
out there close its the palms right out
there's the palms we're just staying at
the Atlantis for about a week a bunch of
our friends we rented a yacht and thirty
of us were partying on yachts
yesterday and the water 95 degrees the
sole property is part of the board a lot
of jamya family it's on the same place
like a lot of different amenities but
let me give you one of the highlights of
the bedroom by the way the bed is
massive this is what the bed looks like
so if you lay down here in bed as I'm
doing right now let me tell you what it
looks like it's great they have this
technology they created here
specifically for those who read a lot
you know how sometimes middle they're
not you reading a book and you forget
what book you're reading and you need to
know the title of the book like we cover
the book they specifically made this for
readers let me show you the mirror you
know what their mirrors for right it's
for extracurricular activities is what
that mirrors for I'll let your
imagination figure that out but we're
having a good time here what a bunch of
friends I'll have some of my friends say
hi to here the only seven star hotel in
the world we're about to leave and go to
Paris make sure what the bedroom looks
like the bathroom beautiful bathroom the
bathtub phenomenal time here the waters
pretty understand how it turns out
that setup lots of details they had it
isn't hers cologne complimentary to
place and then up there you see the
clock
nice little stairs going down service
has been incredible we had dinner last
night
I wonder restaurants on the 27th floor
and it was great
27 for dinner we had I think was a
French restaurant
Almonte or something like that where we
got some friends here let me have them
say hello to you show you what this
looks like the door he announces VND do
not disturb from here anybody who rings
on your doorbell you can literally open
the door from right here you just press
open the door and that opens the door I
set up and we came into this caviar they
treated us very good the whole setup
spinning I've set out a lot of nice
restaurants but can you guys say hello
say hello sexy local baby hi say hello
to everybody this is another view here
it looks like a ship doesn't it doesn't
kind of that will set up it looks
like you were like a sailboat yeah like
I said what is that over there by the
way is that like they said there are no
sharks here the guy said there are some
sharks when we drove in yesterday he
said there are some sharks but not that
many sharks some is better than so mad
did you get a chance to talk to some of
my buddies yesterday who were here did
you ask him who Patrick was in high
school the date what do they tell you
most least likely is it most least
likely because the uh-oh I said I said
hey did you everything Patrick he's
everything Patrick could do something
like this in like Oh No
says why so no Patrick is kind of like
the is kind of like the guy in our in
our inner upbringing you know least
likely see never had any vision he never
had any thought he was competitive but
really have any
vision and so what do you think the
spark was it I don't know I don't know
what the spark is but all I know is that
we really look up to now we woulda never
been able to experience this human
finger or talked about this in high
school so but Patrick uh to frame to be
a successful be aware that right now no
way we they told you what they do for
living today oh yeah yeah yeah I said
how come you didn't go in Akamai you
decided to partner up with other people
in high school but you never wanted a
partner with Patrick says oh no now we
want a partner Patrick Oh Stephen Alfred
man you tell them the horror stories man
when you see the video I'm gonna get you
guys for one of these days but no
Stephen Alfred I'm proud of my buddies
because when when we first when we first
spoke a few years ago these guys
wouldn't want to read a book six seven
years ago when we didn't want to read a
book and I think Steve read he's at 47
books for the year this year it's July
what what's today's date what the 30th
July 30 he's already read 47 books their
business has gone to whole different
level they do very good job of
transportation but you know people ask
how do you go from a past to a different
past today and we were talking about it
earlier when math was doing periscope a
maths appalled if you don't if you don't
know Matt you gotta follow Matt's
Apollo's well Matt your your Twitter
handles about money smart guy money
smart guy is that on Twitter and
periscope it's Twitter okay Matt's
Apollo but but the conversation came
about recreating yourself and it's
probably one of the most difficult
things to do to recreate yourself into
the identity you want to be you know I
wrote a book called 25 loss for doing
the impossible and a first ten laws were
on how to recreate yourselves the
hardest thing you'll ever do then it's
identifying your cause then it's
actually going out there making history
and a big part of this when you sit here
we're having dinner last night with
friends upstairs 27th floor and I'm
having a conversation with them saying
for a moment for yet about the amount of
money we're making forget about the
lifestyle we have forget about the fact
that we're at a hotel that's three grand
a night and we're not even
can I to stay at a place like this
forget about the fact that we're here
renting a yacht and 84 foot yacht and
we're jumping off the top and were full
on service full on dinner barbecue lamb
chops hummus every single drinks
everything was paid for on the yard
music just just imagine what you see in
hip-hop videos it was kind of like a
hip-hop video wasn't it Mike
it was ballers TV it was ballers TV is
what it was you would have never said
that my high school friends would never
said that so last night we're having
dinner I said take a quick moment and
you got a pause and and just quickly be
grateful for the life and enjoy the
moment today cuz this thing goes very
quickly and they're on one side you got
to be extremely ambitious driven speed
everything fast to want to build it big
and get after your dreams and hungry
thinking big all of that stuff buddy on
the other side you also got to be able
to manage that with stayin at the moment
on a daily basis and just being thankful
and grateful while being extremely
competitive believe me it's a very weird
combination but one of them keeps you
sane the other one keeps you driven
being grateful keeps you sane
being extremely ambitious and thinking
big keeps you going to the next level
and staying competitive and edgy to the
point where you don't need your typical
eight hours of sleep you're fine going
on four to six hours of sleep because
your brain is thinking about the next
challenge you want to overcome the next
vision you want to turn into a reality
the next dream you want to turn into a
reality
it completely thinks in a different way
if you do that and anyone could do that
we're creating yourself as something
that anybody could do but we'll start
with a decision that you got to make for
that to take place you just heard master
Paula talking to my buddies yesterday
and they were telling him how this guy
was a guy in high school that nobody
thought about was going to amount to
anything and one day I picked up a first
book and the first book was how to win
friends and influence people and the
next thing you know I'm not picking on
my eleven hundred book that I'm reading
and that's happened in the process of 15
years and anyone can do that you don't
need a half a million dollars to go to
school to get a degree you don't need to
be part of a Vanderbilt family or Gates
family to do that you simply need to
make a decision to go out and commit to
self education and get clear on your
purpose and your vision and the rest is
history and you'll be out here with us
the next
partying in bullish a lot up in Dubai
and some tells me we're probably coming
back here pretty soon again celebrating
because we're sitting here today talking
about where the next places were going
London Germany Australia
Prague what else did we say Costa Rica
Vargas what else did we say Greece
Argentina Panama we've got to go to the
Panama Canal Brazil on this side
Philippines Philippines will go to
Philippines and then if you're tough
enough I'll take you to Tehran Iran with
you and and and really enjoyed the
intense fireworks they have the best
viral works over there you'll enjoy with
us but go recreate yourself it will be
painful but very very well worth it very
very well worth it
we'll see you guys again on the next
episode everybody take care bye bye